- Après deux ans d Q Q Q Q Q Q c
a mis la main sur une vedette
pour sa 11ème a d d d'existence,
au Diamant : le cinéaste Oliver
mais aussi un vaste répertoire.
MARTIN GENOIS, directeur
C'C'C'C'C'C'C'C'C'C'C'C'C'C'C'C.
Il a marqué, par son travail,pls
ont aussi marqué des grands
changements dans la culturepopo,
politique américaine avecles déé
son film "JFK".
- Oliver Stone a rencontré
les journalistes en compagnie
de l'historien James D'Eugenio
dont les recherches l'ont
à son célèbre film de 1991. "JFK
Revisited" contient de nouvelles
Ainsi, ce n'est pas le cerveau
du président qu'on voit sur
les photos. Il était trop
La maglelelelet que Lee Harvey
Oswald aurait tiré, seul, n'a
jamais existé. Bref, le rapport
Warren : c'est un tissue
de mensonges. q q q q q q q q q?
h h h h h h h h h h h h h h h t
catégoriques : John Kennedyaiaie
et instaurer la paix
avec l'Union soviétique,frfrfrf.
Des intérêts puissantsaiaiaiaia,
c'est leur théorie.
Ce n'était pas le sujet,
maisonononononone a-t-il perdu
le respect qu'il avait pour
Vladimir Poutine depuis
après l'invasion de l'Ukraine,
qu'il a clairement condamné sur
Twitter? Il répond plutôt ceci :
Oliver Stone, provocateur,
empêcheur de tndndndndndndnd,
metteur de bâtons dans
les roues, va-t-il continuer ?
- Non si ça marche pourquoi m m.
Si ça marche... Si ça marche,
c'est bien, si ça marche. Mais
si ça devient dangereux pour
le monde oui, il faut mettre
un bâton.
- Vous allez continuer?
À faire ça?
- De sauver le monde?
Jean-Michel Leprince,
Radio-Canada, Québe